Вони гинуть не тільки на фронті, але й самі зводять рахунки із життям.
В Україні активно заговорили про проблему самогубств серед військових.
Станом на початок квітня в Антитерористичній операції на Донбасі
взяли участь понад 326 тисяч українців.
З них 554 заподіяли собі смерть.
Більшість цих військових мали ознаки посттравматичного синдрому -
такі дані головного військового прокурора України Анатолія Матіоса.
А у профільному комітеті ВР заявляють
про понад тисячу самогубств за весь час АТО.
Та навіть із меншою цифрою, яку озвучила військова прокуратура,
виходить одне самогубство за кожні 2-3 дні АТО.
І це не враховуючи кількості самогубств серед ветеранів -
ще півроку тому цю статистику ніхто не вів,
а всі демобілізовані одразу набували статусу цивільних.
Хоча зазвичай рівень суїцидів серед ветеранів
значно вищий, ніж в армії.
Військові психологи заявляють -
не існує країни, яка бере участь у бойових діях
і не має суїцидів серед військових.
Причини також типові.
У переважній більшості випадків ідеться про сукупність факторів:
стрес, відсутність підтримки з дому,
сімейні чи фінансові проблеми, розлучення, пиятика,
депресії, втрата мотивації та цілей.
Зокрема, серед добровольців чи спецпризначенців
значно рідше трапляється пригнічений стан та депресії,
аніж серед мобілізованих.
Але найголовніша причина суїцидів -
брак психологічної підтримки бійця або ветерана.
Найголовніший рецепт для бійців АТО -
е будь-яка психологічна підтримка:
товаришів, командирів, родичів, капеланів, фельдшерів,
волонтерів,  випадкових знайомих.
Ветеранам часто бракує уваги держави.
Чиновники зволікають з оформленням їм пільг,
наданням земельних ділянок тощо.
Ветерани значно гостріше реагують на брехню, корупцію, байдужість.
Ситуацію змінила б глобальна інформаційна компанія з підтримки ветеранів АТО
та їхньої адаптації у цивільному житті.
Для прикладу Сполучені Штати регулярно проводять
соціологічні дослідження та відповідно до цього
змінюють протоколи з реабілітації ветеранів та профілактики суїцидів.
У Данії, яка бере активну участь в операціях ООН та НАТО,
держава проводить конкурси з програм адаптацій,
які виграють неурядові організації,
університети, ветеранські спілки.
У результаті уряд фінансує усі можливі шляхи
допомогти колишнім та чинним військовим.
В Україні ж гостро бракує військових психологів -
на всю країну їх не більше трьохсот.
Крім того, державна програма психологічної реабілітації
досі обмежується реабілітаційними центрами,
організованими місцевою владою та волонтерськими організаціями,
а також санаторіями для Міноборони,
де в якості засобу від депресій та посттравматичного синдрому
пропонують фізіотерапію - душ Шарко та електрофорез.
Але й навіть це поки не працює,
визнають у офісі уповноваженого президента
з питань реабілітації учасників АТО.
Програма державної психологічної реабілітації учасників АТО
не виконується, бо немає затверджених на 2018 рік
протоколів роботи.
ож, попри благі наміри та начебто виділений бюджет,
результатів - досі обмаль.